alors pour le moment le gouvernement
nommé par les talibans n'est pas reconnu
par la plupart des dirigeants exigent
avant plusieurs conditions parmi elles
le respect du droit des femmes et son
engagement à laisser partir des demis ce
temps ceux qui le veulent alors comment
se positionner face aux talibans la
communauté internationale devrait lever
des fonds et comment contrôler si
l'argent utilisé pour venir en aide à la
population afghane c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soir
est avec nous pour en parler olivier
crown ancien officier en afghanistan
ex-conseiller politique à kaboul bonsoir
olivier crown merci d'être avec nous
shoukria haïdar sur ce plateau
présidente de l'association et negar
association de soutien aux femmes
d'afghanistan bonsoir à vous madame
merci d'être avec nous olivier chrome
tout d'abord une réaction à ce
témoignage évidemment émouvant convient
d'entendre ce papa endeuillées qui a
perdu son fils engagé en afghanistan au
début du reportage on l'entend il dit il
est mort pour rien sous-entendu
aujourd'hui voilà vingt ans après on est
au même point au point zéro peut-on le
comprendre de penser c'est ce qu'il y a
de vraies du vrai dans ce constat
terrible
du bien tout d'abord je tiens à jour est
souligné
le courage de ce père qui a perdu son
fils et salué également
la mémoire et le sacrifice de ces
soldats étaient tombés au combat je suis
donc moi même un ancien de l'existant et
je peux comprendre ces questions que
peuvent se poser ou que se posent les
familles lorsque les bars que leur leur
fils ou leur fille tombe tombe au combat
la barre
maintenant je tiens à souligner qu'il
n'est pas mort pour rien il n'est pas
mort en vain le sacrifice de nos soldats
n'a pas été en vain nous avons été
engagés là bas dans une mission pour
défendre des intérêts stratégiques
il faut le souligner les talibans
al-qaïda et les talibans ce n'étaient
pas nos amis
s'étaient l'afghanistan à ce moment là
était le foyer du dualisme du terrorisme
international donc
avion je dirais de bonnes raisons
d'intervenir à ce moment là maintenant
il est toujours facile d'engager de
s'engager dans un conflit il est
beaucoup plus difficile d'en sortir mais
une personne peut savoir comment tout ça
allait se terminer personne ne pouvait
le savoir à ce moment là donc je le
répète
les soldats le sacrifice de nos soldats
là-bas n'a certainement pas été rare ça
ça je tiens à le dire en tout cas
aujourd'hui de nombreuses voilà ma
critique mais enfin constat vingt ans
après c'est vrai que il y a des
interrogations est ce qu'on est revenu
au point zéro c'est aussi l'objet de ce
décryptage ce soir est évidemment la
question tourne beaucoup autour du droit
des femmes notamment
shoukria haïdar un geste aujourd'hui
envers les femmes qu'est ce que les
taliban à l'aise dans leur grande bonté
un les collégiennes et lycéennes revenir
en cour aujourd'hui mais on le sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de restrictions les
concernant il y en a tout d'abord aucune
dans le gouvernement contrairement à
leurs promesses c'est quoi c'est un jeu
de dupes c'est se moquer du monde
va écouter les talibans n'ont pas changé
des stratégies et des politiques les
dépenses est né du livre c'est
exactement le même simplement elles ont
mûri et elles ont appris et l'un des
beaux conseiller
pour chercher à se faire reconnaître par
la communauté internationale elles
disent des mots
par des baux gens avec de belles figures
et de bons manière de s'exprimer
mais que derrière le vrai les stratégies
les vrais pense or le vrai militant et
le crie haut et fort
nous appliquons le charia notre charia
non il n'ya pas de doute d'air dans le
territoire où ils ont gagné tout au
début oui elles ont appliqué de choses a
trahi d'ailleurs ils ont changé la
constitution pour aux normes la religion
non au sud pour l'instant c'est un
gouvernement d'afghanistan il faut
qu'ils ont c'est bien clair as-tu
lors ce sont des milices se sentent de
groupe
qu'ils ont compris le territoire mais
elles sont pas reconnues par la
communauté internationale
l'état reconnu internationalement
aux nations unies et dans toutes les
instances internationales c'est
république
islamique d'afghanistan que sièges
partout donc aux elfes ont tous des
potes vient vous aimez ça cherche à
changer vraiment des paroles très gentil
pour justement avoir la reconnaissance
c'est la clef de tout c'est la clinique
bien sûr
olivier crohn aujourd'hui on le disait
les talibans demandent effectivement une
tribune à l'onu comme l'a dit madame ils
veulent être reconnus
aujourd'hui on imagine avec menotté
internationale les pays de l'onu dans
une situation un petit peu embarrassante
quelle stratégie serait la meilleure à
tenir aujourd'hui
à 117
effectivement c'est une question aussi
délicate j'ai envie de dire je rejoins
ce qui vient d'être dit l'instant c'est
à dire tout d'abord les talibans n'ont
pas vraiment changé par rapport à il ya
20 ans je dirais que là la substance à
cela même ils se sont modernisés avec
des comptes twitter etc mais la
substance race la même et le programme
politique reste le même et c'est et
c'est ce qui avait été annoncé de toutes
les manières de leur part c'est à dire
c'est la charia
intégral si je puis dire la littérale
enfin bref la version en tout cas qui
est extrêmement radical est donc
maintenant ils sont en train de
l'appliquer ni plus ni moins c'est ce
qu'ils avaient dit c'est ce qu'ils font
donc pas surprise de ce côté là
maintenant bon ils sont au pouvoir qu'on
le veuille ou non ils sont au pouvoir
ils sont ils ont pris kaboul
est ce que la communauté internationale
doit le reconnaître c'est effectivement
une délicate question 1 on peut pas
évidemment dire qu'il n'existe pas parce
qu'ils sont là ils sont physiquement au
pouvoir à kaboul maintenant est ce que
nous voulons traiter avec l'os est une
tout autre question est là dessus
j'aurais effectivement un avis beaucoup
plus tranchée une chose c'est de ne
reconnaître un pays une autre chose
c'est de vouloir traiter avec donc
la problématique aléas si vous voulez
est ce que le fait qu'il ya un pouvoir à
kaboul c'est une chose le fait qu'
est-ce que de savoir si vous nous
voulons commencer à le soutenir par
parra par des fonds
que ce soit humanitaire ou pas ou
traités avec ce pays en une toute autre
et là dessus je pense que nous devrions
avoir de très grande réserve
effectivement nous avons combattu
pendant un temps nous avons tout fait
pour construire une alternative à ça bon
après 20 ans est un échec vu que c'est
l'ennemi qui prend kaboul ça nous oblige
en rien à de voir les soutenaient une
quelconque manière en tout cas certains
ont choisi de négocier avec eux bien
avant le retrait américain se sont tout
simplement les les américains eux-mêmes
donald trump
lui même qui avait commencé les
négociations aujourd'hui on le répète un
gouvernement exclusivement fedom
contrairement aux promesses
cette constitution qu'on le veuille ou
non qui a été modifiée qui les laisse la
part belle à la charia clairement les
américains pour vous madame à ce qu'ils
se sont fait berner en cette affaire
écoutez pour ma part et pour majorité
tout le problème à présent les
amérindiens entre guillemets le première
démocratie du monde et sa petite devant
un groupe terroriste pour les intérêts
purement économiques
c'est patrice s'aplatissent ils ont
perdu alors
oui mais enfin est-ce qu'ils ont eu le
choix c'est ce sens le choix je tremble
ne pensait qu'un certain nombre
d'affaires elle ne faisait que
d'affaires alors maintenant vous rend
temps qu'il faut et moi en tant que
femme et monsieur en tant que soldat
quelqu'un qui est combatif qui défendez
les valeurs
mais je trouve nous a pas demandé qu'est
ce que nous pensons mais la population
d'afghanistan les gouvernements néo des
alliés et les traiter tout seul avec les
talibans est le fait traiter billiton et
maintenant les talibans veulent
applications et raté des personnes
étaient concernées
maintenant
tout d'abord mois et la totale est de
proposer d'avoir ne reconnaît pas cette
retraitée cette poule où ce ne pas être
un t2 ne reconnaît pas nous ne
connaissons pas comparer d'une baffe
ensuite
j'ai dit haut et fort et clairement et
ça s'est passé comment ma voix shoukria
haïdar c'est la voix de la majorité de
la population d'afghanistan et de la
majorité des femmes et des hommes que je
rencontre en france
nous avons des valeurs à défendre que
vient des millénaires
de rim de démocratie de respect des
femmes avant ces
modifications de
relations humaines et maintenant un
groupe terroriste que monsieur trempe a
fait un accord
et qu'elle savait dire le soutient et
finance est tarifé le projet et que
votre pakistan va avant ma mise sur
l'afghanistan dans aux
sept groupes terroristes s au
triomphe triomphal elles disent haut et
fort nous avons combattu nous avons
chassé le plus grand
force militaire de la planète amérique
avec ses alliés qui sont l'otan c'est à
dire aimer encore la totalité est le
dise clairement c'est mes crayons cd
c'était
culture de débaucher où il est vraiment
nous avons là la devoir devoir je répète
nous aurons le devoir de défendre
nos valeurs qui sont juste bons et n'est
pas celle d'aider les bandes bride des
talibans olivier 30 vous qui avez connu
terrain évidemment quand vous entendez
madame et voilà son témoignage émouvant
effectivement
beaucoup partagent ce diagnostic mais
enfin
voilà est-ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
malheureusement utopique et c'est un
combat qui est désormais perdu non
bien salée pendant un temps nous avons
combattu nous avons essayé de commandes
bien de nous nous avons défendu ces
valeurs que vient de décrire madame et
qui sont des valeurs qui sont également
appréciés intégré par un grand nombre
d'afghans ça c'est une réalité je pense
qu'au bout de vingt ans c'est ce que
nous avons fait pendant 20 ans par par
tous les moyens pas seulement militaire
si lille également économique dans tous
les domaines je pense que le le le deal
entre guillemets qui que d'en parler
madame entre le président trump et les
talibans en ct ça a été en quelque sorte
ça a été fait c'est une réalité un petit
peu derrière le dos du président
derrière en quelque sorte le dos des
afghans ça c'est une réalité les
américains n'ont pas demandé l'avis
d'ailleurs dans ces négociations là
le gouvernement d'asseoir gamine pas
fait partie n'était pas impliqué dans
ces discussions il était tenu à l'écart
c'est est ce que voulait d'ailleurs des
talibans ils voulaient négocier
uniquement avec les américains
maintenant on vend les américains en
tout cas le président l'administration
entre up
au bout de 20 ans dont ils ont jeté
l'épongé ils ont jeté l'épongé parce que
c'était un conflit qu'il y aurait pu
tellement d'années et que
les résultats n'étaient pas ceux qui qui
avait été fixée entre entre guillemets
quoi donc
maintenant est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
faut arrêter le combat enfin il est
difficile d'imaginer qu'on va retourner
là bas ça paraît totalement illusoire
pense pas qu'il en est question
maintenant soutenir mais les valeurs que
nous avons défendues oui et soutenir
effectivement
pas par par d'autres moyens que purement
militaire je dirais un
soutenir les les franges parmi la
population afghane et les forces qui
titille qui était de l'autre côté que
nous avons soutenues pendant toutes ces
années de conflit évidemment évidemment
ça je j'ai envie de dire
les gens ces gens là qui ont le courage
de continuer le combat là bas bien
évidemment on peut pas se désolidariser
vous parliez tout à l'heure également de
l'aide qu'on leur donne de l'aide
effectivement il ya une semaine les
talibans ont remercié d'ailleurs la
communauté internationale qui a permis
quand même de réunir un milliard d'euros
des deux pays la france d'ailleurs à
donner à elle seule 100 millions d'euros
le double des états unis on le voit
apparaître derrière sur cet écran vous
quel est votre sentiment parce qu'on
sait que la population a cruellement
besoin un tiers la population au seuil
de la pauvreté on ne mange pas à sa faim
mais est ce que dans le même temps il ya
un risque que cet argent soit détournée
par les talibans est pas du tout utilisé
pour la population vous le craignez ça
c'est sûr oui mais je pense qu'il ya des
suffisamment des instances
internationales et de des associations à
haut niveau d
agir au niveau mondial comme médecins de
monde et
autant d'autres elle vox d'argent soit
arrivé au niveau de population parce que
les pauvres dont ils ont besoin il faut
prier mort de faim et de maladie ça
c'est sûr mais pas quelque chose dans
les mains des talibans
d'une base d'autre part pour répondre à
notre ami je me permets de vous appeler
ami
cher monsieur
aujourd'hui les femmes afghanes à
travers de différentes et départements
face à face aux talibans elle raconte
bord trois noms différents départements
les hommes se lève pour défendre
et se mobilisent
comme résistance
s'il est tellement gagner d'un seul coup
tout le département c'est le papa spears
plus fort parce que l'homme de manière
dont hp fournira les autres et les états
unis avaient manigancé est sûre je sens
les chefs militaires et police et de
leur demander de sortir et rentrer les
armes et les départements aux talibans
donc cette manière là qu'ils ont gagné
même les deux départements grâce et 5,6
une semaine son autorité avant que les
tellement arrêt de récupérer donc c'est
pas qu'ils ont battus qu'ils sont forts
qu'ils sont vraiment gagner donc on
voulait d'une manière leur rendre sur le
plateau en oeuvre le l'afghanistan donc
maintenant je ne veux pas beaucoup dansé
dans ce débat simplement comme ça va
s'il vous plaît surtout pour les
résistances des femmes afghanes
soutenons les résistants des hommes dans
tout l'intérieur de l'afghanistan tous
ces hommes 1 et c'est cette fameuse ce
monsieur qui parle de son enfant qui
sont morts pour la pourpour des valeurs
ces valeurs qui sont les nôtres de
l'élection du président afghan depuis
millénaire la culture de tels énoncés le
pas de culture de nous ce que nous
pourrions la haye on a compris en tout
cas leur message sofia ida remercie
d'avoir témoigné merci également olivier
crown d'avoir été avec nous avoir
apporté aussi votre précieux éclairages
merci à vous